for the last year Tulisa Contostavlos
says she's been through how a Sun on
Sunday sting implicated her in a drugs
deal last week the trial against her
fell apart when the judge said there
were strong grounds to believe the
undercover reporter moszer Mahmood had
lied as an earlier hearing it's been a
real roller coaster it's been a journey
the hardest year of my life but at the
same time the positives that I can take
for it now I do believe everything
happens for a reason and I feel like the
life experience that I've fit into one
year it's like ten years worth and as
much as it's been absolutely you know
horrible I wouldn't wish it on my worst
enemy
at the same time he learned your real
strengths and how strong you are in the
worst of situations when you don't have
a choice and I wouldn't I wouldn't have
said before okay push me to that limit
to see how much I can handle but now
that I've come out of it I feel like a
better stronger person for it I mean
there were a reports that you attempted
suicide is that true and if so I mean
why I think halfway through I think I've
done six months of the fear and feeling
who these emotions and I was very down
very depressed and then I found out I
was being charged and I was told that
this could probably and will go on for
another six months and I could face you
know out to four years in prison and in
that moment I've been pretty hopeful and
because I knew what was happening was so
wrong I was like there's no way they can
take it this far there's no way you know
they're going to see you know we're
going to show them Overton's they're
gonna see what's happened and what
they're doing and when I found out I was
being charged and what I just I just
lost all hope
I just didn't have anything any fight
left in me and I felt a little possessed
I don't know who that person was but she
was very weak but in a very dark place
and but you know what the main thing is
is that I picked myself back up after it
and I only continued to get stronger and
and stronger and the person that you see
in front of me today isn't the person
that was in that very dark place six
months ago
the fake Sheikh posed as a film producer
and led to Lisa to believe she was in
the running for a three and a half
million pound film deal
along with Keira Knightley and Kate
Winslet she says she played up to the
role of a bad girl do you think you were
naive and believing him maybe Alex you
know it's funny because uh I would think
me as well I'm very I'm all about tough
love so I'll be how could you be so
Steven and have a go at myself but no
the way that they did it was so extreme
and intense like I didn't even know that
was legal for them to do that and I keep
saying it there's a difference between
entrapment and setting someone up you
know entrapment is where you sit out a
trap and if someone falls into it they
fall into it a set up is where you're
setting them up to fall whether they
fall into the trap or not and that is
what happened to me and it's I just
think I didn't even know they were
allowed to do that then I don't think
they up which is why I've seen the child
collapses because they define the
difference between entrapment and us out
but I just don't understand how its
legal entrapment or setup and do you
think it came to court because you were
in the public eye because you're a
celebrity do you think if you weren't
maybe it wouldn't have gone so far how
do you believe that that is my belief
100m I mean do you think that it's a
problem that you use the press in some
ways I mean you're doing this interview
you've made a documentary you play the
game don't you do you think there's any
sort of hypocrisy and that relationship
your relationship with the press I don't
think that look part of my work is
entertainment so it's opening yourself
up to people and entertaining people and
I fully understand the media in the
press come with that but I don't see how
that can in any way shape or form
justify what they've put me through in
the past year and what they tried to do
and I don't you know if I do something
then okay
and I make a mistake print it you know
to say it how it is when however even
you want to say it that's your opinion
but don't create something that didn't
happen there's no justification for that
and so no I I don't I don't feel like
that justifies it and even now like I
fully understand like in the past
throughout my career yes with the media
like you played the game but now this
isn't even about that for me right now
this is about clearing my name
I've had to sit in silence for a whole
year and have them paint me out to be an
absolute monster and this vile person
and now I'm allowed to talk about it and
not do I want the whole country thinking
on that person no because I'm not so I'm
given the chance yes I'm going to shout
it from the rooftops and saying this is
the real story this is what happened and
it's not how they've made me out to me
some of the stuff that I'm coming out
with is ridiculous I mean like being
honest I mean I'm an X Factor judge like
really people think I was running out in
between breaks to like the local street
corner to go and sell some drugs like if
there's wide why would I need to do that
what like what is there's no logic
behind it it sounds ridiculous
last week Talisa was in court again and
was found guilty of assault she says
she'll be appealing the ruling Lucy got
her Sky News